okay everybody I'm so excited today
because I'm joined by Gavin's folks who
plays Lionel strong in House of the
Dragon we're talk spoilers here so make
sure your cop on the show first before
you watch his interview Gavin how you
doing today man I'm good I'm good my
fate is still smoking
from the fire at Harren Hall but I'm
good mate I'm really good thank you how
are you oh I'm good yeah what what a
tragic ending for uh Lionel and we're
gonna talk all about that before we even
get to that craziness
um what was the audition process like
for a part like this uh mental but
actually for me really quick I was one
of the last ones to get cast so I did a
just a self tape and then about
three days later I had to do a zoom
meeting
um with Kate the Carson director and I
thought well I'll have to do another one
with the show Runners and then I got a
phone call two days later saying I got
it I was a bit like really this is like
if this is the job I think it is that
was that was good
yeah no that's really awesome and how
important was your theater experience
for a part like that
um I think there is a certain uh uh
skill set that you can transfer and I
think that's to do with the slightly
heightened language of it
um if you've done a lot of classical
theater or indeed musical theater where
you're speaking in verse or
speech that is not prose it's not how we
chat to each other now then it gives you
a sense of being able to normalize that
to make it naturalistic
yeah for sure and I could totally see
that with the show like this and was it
scary for you being cast in such a huge
property like Game of Thrones yeah can I
swear yeah sure go for it I I [ __ ]
myself yeah
um I was over the I mean I was I cried
when my agent called I cried I was
getting a it was in the time of um pcrs
I was getting PCR for another film job
and my agent called me and I was waiting
for a result of that test and I sobbed
like a child
and then I thought oh my god I've got to
do it now I've actually got to be in
this thing and try and do a decent job
and it was incredible the first day was
terrifying because it was surrounded by
like Reese Evans and Paddy considine
Graham McTavish Bill Patterson David
Horowitz they're all and Paddy's one of
my absolute Heroes so it was terrifying
yeah I could imagine that's awesome to
hear though that you you take it so
seriously and that it means a lot to you
that's that's really cool and it's
interesting you mentioned Patty so was
that a great experience just acting wise
having him as your main C partner most
of the time anything you learned from
him oh [ __ ] it I was nicking stuff and
stuff from him all the time I could I
was stealing everything but he's such a
he's a very generous actor and he's a
and he's a very generous man
um and he taught me I'd never been on a
set longer than three weeks until I got
this job
and what I really learned from Paddy was
the the idea of how to pace yourself for
for a job like this where you're maybe
doing one scene for a whole day that
doesn't usually happen in anything else
so when you've got that much time you
don't know when to keep your powder dry
when to you know just keep that balance
um and I talked to him quite a bit about
that and but then he just keeps you in a
good mood most of the day because we
[ __ ] around a lot I love that and it's
interesting you just mentioned pacing
yourself what I want to know is was it
super challenging in a part like this
where there's so many time jumps like
finding where you are as your character
was that kind of a crazy thing yeah it
was it was yeah I did a scene in episode
five
um and I hadn't shot uh
anything of five for about two months or
something
um and then we came to do the scene
and thank goodness Ryan condle was it
was in the room I said oh right because
this is a few months later and he was
like no no Gavin this is like three
years later and I'm like oh [ __ ] right
okay yes that that does change things
slightly thank you
um but you've always got these brilliant
people around continuity Etc to help
yeah for sure and it's it's so cool as
seamless the whole cast does that and
it's interesting just speaking of Patty
I'm just thinking about viserys here a
great quote he had to Lionel where he
says your advice has been Sage unmarked
by self-interest which stands in
contrast to all others Would You Gavin
agree with that about Lionel or think
the stars is kind of wrong there
no I think I think 100 he's
the only time
that is the only time he's ever going to
say something that would be
controversial because he knows the king
doesn't didn't
want to accept that news was being
willfully blind
and he was a very
loyal decent man Lionel his family had
all been like that his father his father
and grandfather uh was it his father his
grandfather
his uh grandfather had been handed the
king Osmond so there's a tradition of
being very um loyal people and not
really having I mean he's a lord he
doesn't need for anything and I don't he
never really wanted to sit on the Iron
Throne it's just this madness of
everybody else in this series is like
they want to sit on this massive piece
of metal that he wasn't like that yeah
that that's interesting answer and it's
interesting too because you mentioned
his grandfather but I'm also wondering
too with Lionel in the books also two
daughters he has he had three wives are
you considering any of this in your
portrayal or is important to kind of
just keep that separate and focus on the
script is I def well I read all the
sections I felt the revolving around
Lionel and moments that I felt were
important for my story in the in it um
so I read a fair amount of the book but
I I like to use it as like a given
circumstances just like a load of food
sitting in the background so it is all
there there is a knowledge of that I
went to the Citadel I had six links he's
an intelligent man he doesn't he knows
all the laws of the kingdom and he
doesn't he's so he was so he always felt
very um
knowledgeable that he never questioned
himself or his motives
it felt very pure
yeah and it's interesting too because
I'm also wondering with the character of
Lionel what do you imagine went wrong
with his son Loris like what why why is
he so troubled why does he end up
killing his own father and his son what
what happened there yeah well we talked
about it actually
um Ryan and myself and Matt Needham who
plays Laris about where's this
bitterness come from where's this lust
for his power and Etc and we decided
that
unfortunately during that period
we call it a medieval period they
weren't giving to people with
who are different you know and that
happened with um uh your man in um
Thrones I forgot the character's name
now
Peter um Tyrion Tyrion yes you know the
[ __ ] that he went through and it
motivated him and the same things
happened with Laris is born with his
club foot and maybe he had been treated
poorly by his father and his other
siblings
um not necessarily I think by Harwin but
I think maybe we did actually come up
with the story that maybe his mother
died in childbirth and there was a
bitterness from Lionel towards him about
that
um because why did Lionel have so many
wives and we figured well maybe one of
them's died in childbirth and maybe it
was because of this deformity he'd had
and
so there was there was something there
we worked out there was a bitterness
okay yeah so it's not like he's just
getting around town line with all these
different wives I I like that answer you
gave and it's interesting too it seems
like you guys didn't film everything in
order so did you like jump into the
death scene with Lionel like did you
always know episode six was gonna be the
final episode like how did that kind of
go about with the death yeah no I I knew
son as soon as I was um off of the gig
what what it was
which was heartbreaking
no I want to be optioned for six years
please
um but I knew what it was going in but
of course
the same as doing any piece of drama you
can never play the final scene you can
only play the moment that you're in
um so it was always sad to know that we
were going to film that scene but um I
had a horrendous cold the day we filmed
it and I had a really bad cough it
wasn't covered because we were being
tested with an inch of our lives and I
couldn't I had to scream when I was
banging this door down oh I had no voice
sounded like some sort of deranged seal
I think it's a blessing there and yes uh
it's interesting too do you see like
just how we're talking about the
character it seems like to me there's a
lot more to explore with him in his past
could you see maybe there's a
possibility we see him return in some
fashion maybe another prequel series or
anything like that oh I I'd love to I
mean what's interesting is this 10 years
there's 10 years that's happened between
well you know you know very well
there's 10 years between those steps
five and six
and Lionel's been the hand of the king
for those 10 years and there's been
peace and actually things apart from
viserys's Health have been ticking along
all right
so there is opportunity for something to
happen there but there would have to be
some drama or backstory it'd be in it'd
be it'd be a stretch but you never know
in this world oh yeah I think people
would love to see it too and I mean many
fans are already saying that he's the
best hand ever in the Game of Thrones
universe is that a good feeling to hear
that you're so loved by fans's character
and also do you agree with him being the
best hand in this universe that we've
seen
that's a really tricky question as an
actor and as a viewer I'd he's not as
exciting okay you know uh there's some
certain Lannisters that
were rather fascinating
um hands of the king
um it's it's very rewarding to know how
much they loved him because we felt that
he was you know with the showrunners and
the other writers we felt that he was a
very decent man and hopefully that would
be reflected but you can never tell what
a reception of a character is going to
be until
it is out there so I think yes that's
been really rewarding
um I mean it's not me I mean it is
Lionel I mean I think I'm quite
I don't I I smile a lot more than Lionel
and I talk a lot more than Lionel
but in essence it's just me wearing his
shoes so it does there's a nice uh he'll
always have a special place definitely
and I yeah and it's nice that the fans
have felt that way it's lovely yeah yeah
but but big reason that too is your
performance so that's part of it and I
think that it wasn't you it wouldn't be
the same reaction so oh thanks Steve
that's very kind cheers oh no no problem
and also Before I Let You Go Gavin um I
want to know too what in your just whole
career what will you take away most from
this experience just as an actor and
maybe just as a person with being on
such a big show with such a good
reception
I don't know what one thing I would take
away because it was the greatest uh
professional experience of my life
really I had ever I loved being on set
anyway wherever I'm filming I enjoy
being on set with
you know especially on something this
big but you know there was over there's
1400 people I think maybe even 1800 I
think I can't remember the number
working on the production and you get to
know so many of them so well intimately
and they were so good everybody is so
good at their job
that it reinforced my love of all the
different departments how I really am
fascinated by
you know the grips and the dolly
um boys and you know the Gaffers and and
all the hair and makeup and I just
really love the people on set and it has
reinforced that and how much I love
doing it because I spent 20 odd years
mainly being in the theater
which I love as much in a very different
way but it's there is something special
about the people on the on the TV and
film set yeah and I mean I'm excited to
see what you do next I think it's great
exposure for you and people to kind of
follow your career who are big TV nuts
like me so Gavin thank you so much for
joining me today man and everybody watch
House of the Dragon every Sunday 9pm
Eastern HBO HBO Max I hope to talk to
you in the future one day man thanks so
much thanks Steve thanks for having me